Good morning.
Today we have with us,
Martha Stewart
and Martha's doubts are really impressive and we think a lot about stats and
data here at Google,
but these are pretty amazing.
37 million readers,
users,
viewers and listeners.
Each month she inspires them to celebrate art and their everyday living through
cooking,
entertaining,
gardening,
decorating,
crafting,
organizing,
their holidays,
weddings,
pets,
their entire lifestyle.
And today we're here to look at her most personal book,
yet she literally invites readers into her home for a year's worth of
celebrations across all times of day and all seasons.
This book is a return to her first book,
entertaining,
which actually established worth as a household name or than 30 years ago.
And this is her 75th buck.
And I thought I heard that I'm Jay Leno and I thought it was a joke,
but it's actually her 75th buck,
1800 recipes each year in her magazines,
properties and Martha Stewart show.
And she's also won 18 Emmy's and approximate to our industry.
She's also won the Webby for the best lifestyle website.
Please welcome Martha Stewart.
Hi everybody.
Oh,
we are so delighted to have you
here.
I just tweeted,
we're so excited to have you heard that you can see the Googlers are all just so
excited that you've made the shrimp.
Very happy to see us here in mountain view.
And I'm going to ask you a few questions.
We have questions from the Stroller,
but we'll have questions from the audience later.
We've also been collecting questions ahead of time.
And actually the first one was a bit of a joke from Ted [inaudible].
He asked,
do you have any suggestions for decorating Charlie's cafe,
which is the room.
The flowers are very fancy for Charlie's cafe.
Well thank they are succulents and orchids and roses.
Very beautiful.
Um,
no,
you can't decorate a place like this.
Yeah,
it's all,
it's already,
it's already the place and it's so exciting to be here.
I'm really happy to
functional space.
I'm not a very decorated space.
Um,
but all I wanted was to go ahead and start off with is where you started because
I think that what a lot of people don't know.
Uh,
and I was surprised.
I got to visit your office and your studio last year is that you actually
started off as a model.
I do.
World renowned model.
We actually had this beautiful photo of Martha when she was,
and of course we also have the Google image search and you type in Martha
Stewart
model.
And where does that waste go?
John Dunning.
Just,
just,
just stunningly,
stunningly beautiful.
And I guess I would love to hear the story of how you went from a model to
becoming a do it yourself icon and you,
well,
before I was a model I was actually a student,
uh,
and um,
during high school in order one of six kids,
my father was a pharmaceutical salesman and my mother was a teacher,
a sixth grade teacher,
and there was no extra money to go to college.
There was no extra money to buy beautiful clothes.
And I love beautiful clothes.
My mother,
who was a,
who was quite well dressed,
but she made everything.
So we learned how to sew.
Either had to do all those homely things at home.
But,
um,
so I started modeling when I was 13 and a to pay for extras like college and,
uh,
and it was,
it was very successful because,
uh,
in those days,
college was only $3,500 a year,
including room and board.
And that's very cheap compared to what it is now.
55,000,
75,000,
whatever.
Um,
and so I,
um,
so I did commercials,
television commercials,
and I did a print print ads and print editorial and it was a lot of fun and it
paid $50 an hour at that time,
which was a lot of money.
And,
uh,
and I,
and my commercials appeared on things like Gunsmoke and a Wyatt Earp and uh,
and different.
So it was,
it was a very,
very good way to earn money.
So it wasn't really an older,
in college I went to Barnard College at Columbia University and that time too,
I was modeling.
And then how did you make the transition from model to,
you know,
to whatever your own Tammy or,
well,
really I do it yourself.
Well after college and during college I was a,
my,
my father in law happened to be a stockbroker.
He added a seat on the New York Stock Exchange and I got interested in
investing.
Um,
it was,
uh,
it's interesting then really as it is now,
although the money wasn't as great.
Um,
but you could if you invested in Mcdonald's for example,
in the early days,
um,
it was,
uh,
that was one of the most successful investments or in a thing like it was called
Leasco data processing.
Very good investment if you bought warrants,
um,
on warrants.
Um,
and you invested kind of crazily like my little firm that I belonged to.
I became a stockbroker,
um,
right after college because I thought that that would be an interesting way to
learn about business.
And it was because I learned about how a good company or even a bad company,
a function.
But this is before big time to ecology.
And,
uh,
I gave up the stock market after about an eight year career,
which was,
uh,
which I loved very much and I started a catering business.
The catering is what led me into the lifestyle business.
And the writing,
my first book in 1982
as well,
Martha Stewart Living,
I'm the media,
I get started.
Oh well I wanted to a,
I had so many ideas for lifestyle.
Uh,
and I realized that there were voids in the media world.
There was no one book,
for example,
like entertaining that would teach you a really the basic basic tenants of good
home entertaining.
Uh,
there was no great garden book.
There was no great.
Uh,
and these are illustrated books.
I loved photography.
I loved a colored photography especially.
And,
uh,
so I,
I went to my publisher and I said,
I'd like to do a whole series of beautiful how to books,
uh,
so people could really learn how to do everything.
Uh,
and they said,
Nah,
it's all right,
but you know,
you just keep writing your book a year.
And I was writing a book a year.
And so then I went to sign new house,
uh,
who is the head of Conde Nast publishing.
And I told him my idea and he said,
well,
that sounds like a magazine.
And a,
so I gave him a proposal for a magazine and um,
and then it went,
it went on from there.
So I started Martha Stewart Living,
uh,
the magazine,
with,
not with Connie Nas,
but with Time Warner in 1990.
And from there,
everything else has,
uh,
has grown,
especially the idea of synergy between media,
television,
um,
bringing all the,
all kinds of media together.
Uh,
and then of course intranet and then a merchandising.
You can stay the whole array of different magazine.
Yeah.
Those are probably isn't even all of them.
Yeah,
that's,
yeah.
You're missing every day.
Food magazine format.
So what were the early days at Martha Stewart Living Life?
Well,
it was so much fun.
We were,
we considered ourselves a microcosm of a big media company,
Time Warner,
uh,
and we were very proud of being that microcosm.
We were put on the most unfriendly floor in the time that in the Time Warner
Tower on sixth avenue below us.
Oh,
below us was all the mechanics of the building.
So my feet,
my feet were warm because it was a hot floor and probably an unhealthy floor.
I hated it.
The windows didn't open.
I will,
we run them like 50 something Florida and you wouldn't want your windows to open
up there.
Um,
so it was an unhealthy in that respect,
a no fresh air,
um,
hermetically sealed.
And ever since that little time I stayed in that office for about a year and a
half and I begged to move and we found a space that with windows that opened
with fresh air,
with natural gas for the stoves,
for our kitchens.
All that meant a lot with me.
Sunlight,
daylight.
It was important.
It was very important.
And,
uh,
and ever since then we've,
and you've been to our office and uh,
you know that we have sunlight and daylight much like you have out here,
only much smaller.
Well,
you're here in Silicon Valley and it's the heart of innovation.
Uh,
and you're one of the few people in the world who's actually defined in
industry.
So what words of advice do you have for young entrepreneurs?
So as to how they might try and do the,
do the same and a lot of people here who are entrepreneurs within Google and
trying to build new businesses and new categories themselves.
Well,
again,
it's finding okay
void I think in,
in your area of interest and expertise,
finding that void that other people really also consider a void and building in
that void,
something that is so original and so enticing and so a desirable that many other
people will have to come there.
Uh,
I mean,
that's what Google is.
you had to come to Google.
I mean is there was no choice.
There was no other way.
Uh,
there were other companies,
but it was by far the most interesting place to go.
Uh,
I was an early adapter or adopter of technology and I bought my first computer.
It doesn't sound like very long ago,
but 1982 I bought my first IBM computer a PC.
I still have it.
And uh,
does it,
I haven't,
I haven't plugged it in.
I haven't even tried.
I haven't even tried,
but I still have it.
That's silly looking.
Yeah,
little thing.
Um,
but it was so interesting what was going on and um,
and I've tried to keep up,
uh,
I know there's lots,
I don't know,
but as much as as I can,
I keep up with the,
with the newest,
uh,
and um,
I watched with interest the new IPOs that are happening like the Groupon this
morning,
um,
and uh,
and testing the waters her for what else we are going to be distracted with and
our quest for our own particular interests.
Right.
Yeah.
There's a lot of distracting stuff out there or is it really
it's not,
it's interesting.
We're one a half a mile.
I'm down the road from the Computer History Museum,
which always to me it seems like an oxymoron,
a short history,
but it's really amazing.
It's like it was more like a fragment.
So what are the three,
if you had to name three really important lessons that you've learned throughout
evolving your business,
you've been so successful,
what are are,
are three of the most important lessons you will find it,
right?
That finding that niche that interests you and will interest others.
That's one very,
very,
and a niche.
I,
a niche can be as big as the Grand Canyon,
you know,
it says not has to be,
it doesn't have to be a tiny,
tiny little space.
It can be a giant space.
Uh,
and then creating content or something to fill that cavern a or canyon with
something really valuable and will made,
uh,
and it can be pretty too,
like you're beautiful Google maps,
uh,
like your like and like so many things that,
that you find on the Internet that are,
that are appealing to the eye but understandable at the same time.
And then third,
just continue with it.
Uh,
and,
and don't forget to look elsewhere.
Don't forget,
look at what's coming up behind you,
what's coming in front of you.
Uh,
always keeping is as current as possible.
Okay.
And you have so much variety in your business.
You know,
there's cooking cause,
crafting,
there was organizing,
there's a Bunnings,
there's,
there's blogging,
there's tweeting,
there's the TV show,
there's the radio show.
How do you decide to go into a new area?
How do you decide to explore a new venture?
We were,
we were very avid,
um,
explorers and all kinds of media in the first place.
Um,
we were also very avid in exploring a retail business,
merchandising businesses.
Um,
and we continue to be,
so,
although we now know that you cannot even as a,
as a corporation do every single thing that you want to do and,
uh,
and you must concentrate on those areas that are really the most profitable,
the most interesting,
the most had the most future have the most growth potential.
So that's what we're doing now is,
is figuring out with our company,
our small company,
uh,
what really we should be focusing on.
Okay.
Well we have a little video I would like to add to show because one of the
things we've seen is that users are constantly googling you.
They're constantly googling you,
your crafts,
your ideas,
your recipes,
the products.
And so you can just see there's a so much inspiration and you've given you,
you've gone to great lengths to make all of your content really accessible.
Um,
and,
uh,
I guess I'd like to start,
did you,
have you made a Croak and Bush?
I have not,
unfortunately.
I can't really cook,
but my husband is a fabulous guy.
So,
um,
do you embroider a I do embroider.
I do.
I do like especially I'm going to say constant.
I do like I do like to sound and I like,
I like to do crafts with LEDs,
but,
um,
so I like to do like light displays and things,
but you know,
people are just obviously been so inspired by what you've done.
And part of it is that you've made so much of what you do really accessible to
them through the internet.
And so I thought I would talk,
I would,
I like you to talk a little bit about how the Internet has changed your
business.
How has made you more accessible to use her?
Well,
it's changed it tremendously.
And,
um,
and we want to be where our customers need and want us.
And more and more of our customers really do want us on the intranet.
As the population of a tablet owners grows.
Uh,
we were,
um,
very aware of that and we wanted to be there with,
uh,
the best apps possible.
I wish we had a picture of the APP that Martha Stewart living a half that we
should have put up.
Sorry.
Um,
but,
uh,
but if you,
if you have a chance to look at it,
I,
I suggest you look at it.
Oh,
the first issue of Martha Stewart living that went up was a specially prepared
issue,
uh,
for the IPAD
and uh,
but it is so amazing,
uh,
how you can transform a print magazine into something alive and vibrant,
more vibrant than the real,
then the real printed magazine.
Uh,
and uh,
and now every month we prepare,
we prepare a tablet versions of our magazines,
a two of them everyday food and Martha Stewart living.
Um,
and the,
uh,
the people who work,
the editors who work on these,
um,
these apps are very happy working on them.
They love creating the imagery,
which is a little different from print photographs,
but the photographers love it.
The editors love it.
The writers love it and the users love it.
They love looking at it.
So,
um,
so we're,
we're doing that.
We have a couple of fantastic apps,
a cookie app,
a cupcake App,
uh,
which,
a drinks app,
that's a really good one.
If you're,
when you get home from work on the,
on a Friday night,
that's a good one to go to for some inspiration.
And so,
so we're doing that.
We're working very hard to get across.
I do a daily blog which reaches,
oh,
on an average maybe a five or 600,000 page views a day,
which,
which for a blog and one of 12 blogs in our company's pretty good.
Um,
and,
but people get to know you,
they get to understand the value of what you're trying to set forth.
Uh,
um,
and,
uh,
and I like that.
It's a personal,
my and my blog is a pretty personal blog.
Uh,
lots of views of snow storms and tragedies and Oh,
they,
the tragedies,
the,
um,
broken trees that those,
those get the most page views,
the death of a dog.
Oh my gosh.
Um,
you know,
it's,
it's sad,
but that's what happens.
They people like that they want to commiserate.
Um,
but the,
but that's um,
so,
and,
and we are a really using as much and the,
the,
even this little device,
the nook a where you just send a pdf of a magazine,
uh,
to the nook.
Uh,
the economics are very favorable.
Um,
and I wonder how would it do,
well actually the books are selling well and the subscriptions,
uh,
via the nooks selling well and so we have to figure it out.
Um,
advertisers haven't figured it out yet.
A publishers haven't figured it out yet.
Maybe Google has answers for me today about what's going to happen here,
but it is,
we're in a very important stage of transition right now with,
uh,
with media especially,
where are you going to access your information regularly?
Is it going to be in that beautiful magazine that you can open and page through
or is it going to be on your tablet?
We don't know for sure yet,
but I can see sort of where it's going
all.
We have some very exciting demos to show you later today.
But yes,
I think we're all really excited about tablets,
particularly android tablets.
And I said yes,
I don't say that point again.
Well we'll make sure we change that today.
We can hook you up with an android tablet.
I had,
I had one in Italian,
doesn't do so well.
Um,
but um,
no,
but yesterday I was talking to one of my publishers who's traveling with me on
this book tour and she and I saying,
you know,
I have all my books in one place now I don't have to have a suitcase just to
carry the books that I'm reading it.
And I used to read a one book from cover to cover and I wouldn't pick up another
book Nerissa I until I finished that book and I knew I was finished with it.
But now with the tablet,
uh,
you can just,
you can put in any number of hundreds and hundreds of books and just pick up
where you left off on any number of books.
And it's a very,
it's confusing.
It is confusing and it's convenient.
It's very convenient,
but it is confusing and it is nice to actually be able to jump around between
the box.
So,
so I'll be on the blog.
One of the interesting things you've done is you've created Martha's circle,
which is actually a community of bloggers and interact with you.
Can you tell us a little bit more about that?
What inspired you?
What are some of the interesting things and then happened in Martha Circle?
Well,
we liked,
yeah,
other bloggers.
We've done programs on our television show of just an audience full of bloggers
and uh,
and they,
we let them blog all during the show.
Uh,
and it's a lot of fun but,
but blogging is kind of a,
um,
wonderful way to communicate with a vast audience and,
uh,
and to get a vast,
a number of opinions about something.
And it's so much fun to see who's doing really well in the blogosphere who isn't
a,
we tried to put in our circle,
um,
bloggers who are actually sort of in tune with what we're doing.
Uh,
maybe even more avant garde or less,
um,
you know,
just,
just to bring a community together,
a bigger community.
That's great.
Well,
let's talk a little bit about the television show.
Uh,
over the years I think you've had,
everybody has it.
You get these amazing celebrities and you're getting them all to do to do crafts
and teach them cooking and everything else.
Who had been the most entertaining?
Do you have some favorite class?
The last week I had,
yeah,
I had Hugh Jackman on and I had just seen his new movie,
real steel.
Which uh,
well it depends if you like,
robots are not
live robots go see it because it's quite extraordinary these boxing robots who
smash each other to death.
Um,
but,
but luckily I had seen it and he is charming,
absolutely charming and,
and very self effacing and a very talented man.
He happens to live across the street and his windows are in direct view of my
daughter's apartment,
so we can sort of watch him and say we wave to each other,
uh,
when he's in there.
So I knew everything he was doing in his apartment.
And he knows everything.
That dinner party,
that was fun,
but he's,
he's a great guy.
Um,
and that is the guests like that who are very,
um,
sort of and get into the,
get into the segment that we're trying to do.
Some actors really are actors and they don't,
unless they have a script and a,
and a and a director,
they really can't do anything.
Right.
Wow.
They even admit,
one actor said to me,
I said,
gosh,
that scene and if the cherry orchard,
it's a checkoff fight.
I said,
Gosh,
you talk about cherry trees.
Like so knowledgeable.
He's,
I don't know,
fuck about it.
Cherry tree
checkoff wrote the words,
I just act,
um,
you know,
and it's fun.
Is there a biggest or funniest mishap this happened on the TV show?
Um,
oh,
mishaps happen all the time.
And the more and more ms that and with comedians especially because they make
mishaps happen and we had one guy,
uh Oh,
we had,
um,
wonder,
we have,
um,
now I'm going to forget all my comedians,
nasal ones I love the most,
but Seth Meyers for example,
uh,
Seth always makes something right.
Bad Habit.
And Conan is very funny.
And Jimmy Fallon,
Jimmy Fallon,
I made him on a,
on a Halloween special.
I made him put his hand in,
you know,
in a secret box,
you'll have to stick your hands through a membrane.
And,
and uh,
I said,
what does it,
what do you feel?
He says,
Eh,
it feels awful.
And then I uncovered it.
It was full of mealy worms.
Live mealy worms never forgiven me.
He's trying,
he's trying to get that.
So let's talk a little bit about the book.
So the first book I have here is,
and this was entertaining.
Yeah.
What was your first book?
Very first,
huge best seller inspired,
I guess all in the books that came after it.
And now your new book is a revisiting it.
Yes.
One.
This one weighs a lot more.
This is like six and a half pounds.
Wow.
Yeah.
It's not a sequel.
It's not because it's quite different print actually.
And the first one was,
um,
was a textbook on how to entertain a picture book with beautiful visuals and a
recipe book.
And this book is really more,
I think,
more cohesive.
And the first book had a lot of parties that I was catering at the time.
Uh,
and this one is really all personal parties.
And I also had,
um,
Betsy Hawes.
Elizabeth has helped me write that first book and I didn't know how to write a
book.
I had never written a book when I wrote that in 1982 and she was such a good
teacher.
Uh,
and that's another thing that anybody contemplating writing or creating
something like that is if you don't know how to do it,
find somebody who does know how to do it and can kind of teach you the method.
Uh,
that's why we go to school.
I mean,
and I,
but I hadn't taken a writing course,
so I found my voice doing that book.
And I was so happy that I did.
And this one,
I wrote every single word and a I write final text if I can,
I think about it a lot.
And we took the pictures for four years.
So,
um,
during that time I sort of what I was gonna say and then I sat down last
Christmas and took until I finished and on my third floor craft room and wrote
away.
So there it is.
And so how did you decide what to include in the book?
Well,
we took pictures.
we,
we um,
created a whole bunch of fabulous parties,
invited real people,
uh,
friends and family and guests and colleagues and photograph them and then a
design the book and then a row the recipes,
and then wrote the book.
It was,
there was a lot left on the,
on the kitchen floor.
Those are those stories I hope will maybe make the next book.
Is there one celebration in there that just stands out in your mind,
is your absolute favorite?
Uh,
well,
I'd like Easter a lot with Easter bunnies.
There's,
there's a really great picture in here of,
um,
my veterinarians daughters who came for Easter.
Did you see the one with the,
with the little girl looking at the giant chocolate rabbit?
Yeah.
Wow.
That is a really big,
bad is a great,
she's uh,
she's smaller than the chocolate rabbit,
but that,
those are fun.
Those are fun and memorable events.
Well one of the things is,
you know,
you do a lot with the holidays.
How do you make the holidays fresh year after year?
How do you reinvent them and,
and it can keep them excited.
Doing my proposal for the magazine was Time Warner.
I remember meeting with,
you know,
the,
the big honchos and I told him,
I showed them the prototype for a July issue in July of course,
includes July 4th.
And they said,
well this is all great,
but what the heck are you going to June next year?
Cause they thought it was finished.
And I said,
I think we could probably not repeat ourselves for 20 or 30 years with all the
ideas.
It's about having creative teams,
about making a new,
uh,
making up new ideas.
Making up new ways to celebrate traditional things.
And that's what we do all the time.
That's cool.
So Thanksgiving's right around the corner.
What are your plans this year?
Oh,
family thanksgiving.
I think we're going to have it in New York City and with some friends and uh,
there's a new grandchild,
Jude,
and we're going to have her sitting at the table,
hopefully ab eating her first piece of Turkey if her vegan mother allows it.
I just want to ask you what your funniest Thanksgiving experience might be,
but that might be the worst.
Worst one
was the first I ever had and I was 19 years old.
Oh,
right after I got married.
Now I must be 20 cause I got married when I was 19.
Then with my first Thanksgiving I was 20,
so I was 20 years old.
I,
I fought large even then.
And I was living in new haven.
My husband was at Yale law school and I was commuting backwards to New York to
go to college.
And I invited his whole family and my whole family up to our little cottage in
the woods in Guilford,
Connecticut,
where we lived on the other side of new haven.
It's stupid,
stupid,
stupid life.
Um,
and uh,
and I,
uh,
down the end of the road is a Turkey farm.
God sees Turkey farm.
And I went there on set on Wednesday to buy my Turkey.
They were all packing up and he said,
well,
it's lucky it came in today because we're taking off her Florida tomorrow.
The farmers and I bought up like 35 pound Turkey and uh,
made the stuffing,
got an already the night before,
set the alarm for 3:00 AM so that the Turkey,
it was 35 pounds,
you know,
I'm turning to minutes a pound.
It takes a long time.
Uh,
would be ready when the guests got there.
And,
uh,
which was about two and a half hours from New York.
Um,
and I fell back to sleep in a dead sleep.
I was exhausted and I had asked my husband to preheat the oven to 300 degrees.
He had just put it on broil.
So we woke up to a house full of black smoke.
The Turkey was totally charred on the outside and this was at 7:00 AM and I
started to cry and I got in the car,
jumped in the car.
My husband thought I was leaving him.
I should have been,
it would have been better.
Better.
No,
I'm just kidding.
Um,
but I drove down to the Turkey farm at the end of the,
it was really virtually at the end of the road and they had one Turkey semi
frozen.
It's still there that they hadn't sold.
I grabbed it,
took it back home to the stuffing out of the older Turkey and put it in and put
it back in the m and Thanksgiving dinner was about five hours late.
But they,
the,
the relatives,
they,
they went along with it and that black and Turkey.
Now there are recipes for black and Turkey.
Well,
story,
sorry.
Well,
we've been collecting questions from Googlers and bomb fall or one of our
Googlers wants to ask,
when entertaining,
what is more important?
Food or presentation?
Food.
And what is your favorite holiday food?
My favorite holiday food,
um,
for Christmas eggnog.
Okay.
And did you have a least favorite dish to cook?
Is there something that you really don't like to cook?
Well,
if I don't like to cook it,
I don't cook it.
So I mean that you,
you have your choice.
[inaudible] nobody's forcing you in your own kitchen to cook something.
Uh,
we recently acquired as a Gat,
uh,
and it was,
it God is all about restaurants.
Do you have favorite restaurants in the world of favorite restaurant in New
York?
Oh,
favorite restaurant.
And we'll just go
in New York.
One of my favorite restaurants just because of the ambiance is wonderful.
The,
um,
the look of the restaurant is x is so exquisite and the food is really,
really good.
It's a Japanese restaurant called n,
e.
N.
Brasserie.
Uh,
the young couple who owns it is a cheese from Tokyo and it's superb food.
So I go there a lot.
Uh,
it's congenial and very,
very nice and it stays open late.
And um,
I liked that one a lot.
But then I like all the great chefs too.
Sure.
Let's change gears to technology.
When did you,
the web was going to be this incredible catalyst for your media empire?
Well,
is there a moment you can pin point where you're like,
wow,
this is the thing is really,
um,
well pretty,
really see I've,
about when we started with our,
with our business on the intranet,
it was immediately a very attractive,
very enticing and very important.
So I would say maybe 10 years ago.
Okay.
Another question from a Gugler Eugenia Vas goes,
asks,
you're quite active on Twitter,
which here's on your right out here.
I just started to follow your boards on Pinterest,
which is a new startup out here that's getting a lot of buzz right now.
Uh,
I'm very impressed that you're actually already on Pinterest.
Oh,
it's getting like they won.
Um,
I find it repetitive.
Oh really?
Yeah.
I don't know why,
but I do.
Okay.
So how well it will hopefully the guys on Pinterest and we'll try and make it
less than that.
Less repetitive.
I love you.
How best you,
is there a particular way that you really like to engage with your fans online?
Cause the penetrance bores Twitter.
Well,
Pinterest parties,
visual.
I'm on Twitter.
I do both,
uh,
both,
twit pigs as well as,
uh,
just tweets and that works very well.
I've two,
almost two and a half million followers who are pretty active.
I love to do instant surveys.
Uh,
so if I'm meeting with a new potential business partner,
uh,
and we did this not long ago with a retailer that I wanted to carry our cleaning
products,
I said,
I just tweeted while I was sitting with the CEO,
I,
I treated,
would you buy my cleaning products at such and such and such a retail outlet?
I got back,
oh,
several hundred tweets within three minutes saying exactly why there's that
story.
Doesn't,
uh,
isn't it near me?
I can't buy it there because I,
it's too far away from my home or,
but instantaneous results.
I love it for that.
And I also love it for instant news because it really does keep you informed on
Facebook is a fantastic way for us to,
um,
to,
uh,
communicate and I just can't wait to really get into our Google.
Yeah.
Plus it's Martha's on
Martha [inaudible],
Virginia actually had a question when she said,
we would really love to see you do a Google plus hangout.
You can actually do an hangout where you broadcast.
Yep.
All your fans let us say you do some demos and some crafts and cooking.
We will do that.
Absolutely.
Uh,
and Judy Chang asks,
you publish your calendar online.
It's full of activities from your book tour and a TV appearances,
mulching your garden,
polishing your silverware,
how many people work on your household staff and how has your sleep each night?
Oh,
this,
the sleeping sorta of like crazy.
Uh,
and it depends on where we are,
what I'm thinking about and what I'm doing.
But in terms of households have,
I have three houses,
uh,
they and they're all open all the time,
so I want to be able to their uses laboratory,
so I want to be able to go there and they're clean and dust free and ready for
pictures.
Um,
so,
um,
anywhere from two and a house to more depending on,
on what we really need to do.
It's a staffing is,
is,
um,
is always a challenge.
Uh,
and keeping a good staff.
My one of my housekeepers has been with me for 30 years.
One has been with me for 27 years,
uh,
there,
and they really know where everything is and I have a lot of stuff.
So
how much of a role does search play in your day to day?
What do you search?
Oh,
uh,
it's a very important part of my day because I do a lot of writing and,
um,
and I oftentimes have to,
uh,
find out something about something,
so I will use it for my research.
Um,
it's a much,
much quicker than going to the local library or to down the,
down the road from my house.
I can't do that.
And,
uh,
so it has,
is a tremendously wonderful timesaver.
Uh,
but at that,
that's it.
I use it for lots of other things to shopping,
of course,
a comparison,
shopping of course.
Um,
for,
uh,
the research for,
um,
uh,
information like maps,
very important to me to know where I'm going and how I'm getting there.
Uh,
so I use it for a lot of things
and we're working on more.
I know that actually when I met you in your studio,
there was this amazing a ceramic bowl.
Uh,
it was just very organic wreckage,
urban bold,
determine ball and Martha said like,
okay,
when are you going to have a search technology that's going to help me figure
out where this goal came from and where I can get more of it we're working on.
We don't have visual search that quite that could mean if it doesn't have a bar
code on it or it doesn't,
it's not a well known,
well known object,
uh,
to be able to,
to photograph it and,
and,
and find it in somebody's catalog that is happening.
I know it's happening more and more every single day.
The day we have Google goggles which can recognize landmarks and products and
have things like bar codes or text on them.
But we're,
we are working on that visual recognition.
I'm going to ask Martha one more question and then we'll go ahead and open up to
audience questions.
So if you want to move to the microphones,
if you have a question,
we'll open it up in just a second.
Uh,
but nice question is about youtube.
So we talked a little bit about search.
You're really active on Youtube,
lots of,
lots of amazing clips that can teach people how to do crafts and cooking.
How do you decide what goes on Youtube?
How do you know what your users really want to see?
Well,
okay,
we're always experimenting and uh,
and during holiday times they want to know how to do Turkey one oh one.
They want to know how to make your program boost.
They want to know how to fold a fitted sheet.
They want to know how to fold a tee shirt.
I mean,
it's,
it's amazing how many different things people really need and want.
Uh,
and we try to keep up with that.
That's cool.
Okay,
let's go ahead and,
and
go to the audience here.
Hi.
Thanks for being here,
Martha.
It's great to hear from you.
Thank you.
You've grown your business into a complete lifestyle empire,
but how do you keep challenging yourself?
What would you like to accomplish the next five to 10 years?
Well,
in the next five to 10 years I would like to work with,
uh,
some of the more,
more impressively progressive people that I've met.
I would like to develop on new ways of thinking about things.
Um,
I would like to build my store,
which I haven't built yet.
And uh,
so there's,
there's a lot of things to do.
Great.
Thank you.
This is great.
This is definitely not as serious of a question.
It's sort of silly,
but how do you fold a fitted sheet?
Okay.
Oh y'all,
quarter by quarter by quarter your has in and there's a certain way which corner
to take.
One,
two,
three,
four.
And it does fold quite nicely.
Not,
not perfectly,
but very nicely.
And it'll fit in your linen closet.
But my suggestion to all busy people do your laundry,
dry the sheet,
put it back on the bed.
Yeah.
Practical and men,
and not every three weeks,
by the way,
I took a survey on Twitter and ask them how often do they change their bids?
I was horrified.
Horrified.
I mean really the average was two weeks.
That's really bad.
Okay.
Well you have to worry about these people who are online all the time.
They get all those surveys,
I guess.
Yeah.
So you created so many recipes,
maybe thousands.
How did you manage to stay sheet at the same time?
Stay what stat?
Heat.
Physically fit.
Oh,
fit.
Oh my God.
Um,
well it's hard because I eat a lot.
I have to taste a lot.
I'll get off a show and then they'll in the kitchen and my test kitchen,
a TV,
they'll have 44 different causal.
For me to taste of choose the best croissant,
it's really hard.
But uh,
uh,
and,
and it's,
it's interesting,
but it's also difficult and I exercise a lot.
I'm a,
I'm not a maniac,
but I exercise a lot.
I eat really well,
at least for my own organic garden.
I'm going to see your garden here.
I understand.
Yeah.
I want to see it.
I grow,
I grow up pretty much all my food.
Okay.
He's in,
uh,
any natural limitations of number of recipes in the world?
Uh,
I don't think so.
I think,
I think recipes are,
um,
can be altered by a teaspoon of this or a tablespoon of that.
And I think,
uh,
we have created original recipes in our company.
Oh,
many,
many thousands of recipes and they're in many of the 75 books that we've created
and all those magazines.
And we're,
um,
we have,
we have a good recipe search on our,
on our site.
Good.
Thank you.
Let's go here.
Thanks again for calling Martha.
This is awesome.
Um,
so I'm curious what you're surrounded by a gourmet organic food and,
and for everyone to sort of look to you as an example and all of this,
are there times when you just want to close the door and splurge and eat like a
TV dinner?
Okay.
MMM.
I haven't found a TV dinner that is that enticing.
Yes.
Uh,
and I,
and I've tasted a lot just to see what's really out there and what people are
putting in their children's stomachs.
And I,
it's pretty depressing.
Uh,
we're working on food now and um,
and it's,
it's very interesting to see who is doing good prepared foods for the
marketplace,
a good ingredients for the marketplace.
I am a very,
very staunch supporter of non factory farming.
I hate what's going on in,
in the factory farms in America and I cannot,
I cannot abide the,
the cruelty to the animals that were being fed to the,
uh,
the way grains are being grown.
Uh,
all this gluten intolerance it's going on is a very serious problem.
And why,
why when I was growing up,
nobody was allergic to wheat.
I don't,
I didn't know one person.
I didn't know.
I didn't know one person with a peanut allergy.
And I don't think it's the peanuts and I don't think it's the wheat.
I really think it's,
what's the processing?
I think it's the way it's being grown.
I think it's the way it's being sprayed,
a fertilized,
uh,
all of that.
And we have to really,
really as a country pay attention to that.
Thanks.
Okay.
It is true
allergies.
Yeah.
So one of the three of us two and then having gluten allergies.
Hello Martha.
Thank you for being here.
I have actually a business related question.
As a leader of an organization,
how do you continue to have all of your staff meet the same level of excellence
and continue to innovate year over year in the areas of creative design,
et Cetera?
Well,
you tried to hire in the first place,
people who have the same DNA as you have a,
you want them to be interested,
interested
in the core content areas of your particular kind of organization.
And we were very,
very,
very good at that.
As an organization grows on that can get away from you and you can be less
choosy or less fussy or maybe there's not as many talented people in those
specific areas as there used to be because there's more competition.
It's a V it's an ongoing challenging problem for any company.
And a,
you just have to have a very good HR department.
Uh,
and one who is looking at a good,
a good search department,
uh,
human resources to find the right people,
for your particular company.
You know,
sometimes I'll people and I say,
God,
what are they doing here?
You know,
not physically,
I don't mean physically,
but when I see what they create,
what the heck are they doing in this,
in this environment?
They just don't have it.
And you have to really be very,
very careful about that.
Hiring is something here.
I can go.
Let me take,
I know,
I know.
Yeah.
Hi,
I'm,
he picked,
inspired me so much.
She created my own home.
I'm for you.
I discovered you.
I couldn't make potato and now I'm bringing pies to all the holiday of it.
Good.
It's awesome.
And I know you have a small corner on your website and in Europe,
magazines dedicated to kids,
but I was wondering if you were really thinking about expanding that to get our
kids to create more.
Um,
we had a wonderful,
a baby magazine and a wonderful kids magazine,
uh,
about Oh eight or nine years ago.
Uh,
it was a fantastic publication of I want to bring that back.
And the reason that we stopped publishing it was advertised lack of advertising.
Uh,
there's not very many magazines devoted to the raising of children to the
teaching of kids.
And I think the Internet is a,
is a more appropriate place actually for that intro,
for that information.
And uh,
we are working on plans to Rayanne live in or in live enliven that,
uh,
that area.
So a watch for it.
Hi.
Obviously you've had a very successful business career today and looking back
over everything related to your company,
what is the one decision that you,
in retrospect,
you wouldn't have made knowing what you know now?
Um,
well I had one horrible stumbling,
which was a stock sale unrelated to the company,
unrelated to anything.
I was on a plane.
I mean I can go through the whole thing,
the whole litany of the,
of the disaster.
Um,
I would avoid disasters,
like legal problems like that forever
because that sets you back terribly and it could have destroyed my company,
but the customers never left.
I advertisers did take scope to the sidelines for a while.
It's,
it's,
and,
and rebuilding something that's beautiful and useful and good is a lot harder
than building it.
So the rebuilding process is painful for me because I'm,
I,
I like,
I never go the same route to the same place ever.
If I can,
if I can avoid it.
And you know,
if there's a straight line,
I will go circuitous leads.
So I might see something new because my motto is see something,
learn something new every day.
So avoiding avoiding with the help of maybe,
um,
you know,
really the best advisors,
uh,
or something you just avoid if you can avoid a disaster and,
and if,
if you fall into that,
into that Crevasse,
um,
get out of it in the,
in the fastest,
best,
cleanest way possible.
Okay.
Thank you.
So,
and let's take two more questions.
Hi Martha.
It's good to have you at Google.
Um,
so I don't actually quite enjoy cooking,
but I think it's because I don't know how to cook.
So my question is,
how do you keep it fun in the kitchen?
What's your advice for someone like me?
Well,
I think
you should take some great cooking lessons if you don't really know how to cook.
And it's hard to teach yourself how to cook.
I watched people and I like to sit like at a Sushi bar and I sat watching Nobu
himself,
do Sushi for a long time,
eating there quite often.
And he finally let me cut Sushi with him and he gave me a Sushi chefs code,
which I'm very proud of because very few people get a Nobu Sushi coat.
Um,
and uh,
so I watch and I learned by Nih and I learned by emulating the very,
very best.
I'm lucky at my job because I can invite any chef on my show and learn from him.
We had Thomas Keller on the other day,
the way he uses his hands and the way his,
the precise nature of his cooking is so,
so interesting.
Uh,
and so you should,
if you're interested in eating,
you should be interested in how that food is made and then it might induce you
to learn.
Thank you.
Yep.
Hi Martha.
Thank you for being here.
I have one question.
Um,
you're very,
you're very successful.
I would like to ask you,
I'm sure you had some difficult times.
How did you put yourself together again and those difficult times?
It just kept on going.
Well,
I'm very strong.
I have good,
good,
a solid family.
Genes behind me have longevity and,
and strange and um,
and when you know that you are okay,
you're okay after of just keep telling yourself and it's,
it's really about,
um,
uh,
not,
not so much self preservation as,
uh,
as knowing that,
what you're doing is useful and good and uh,
and profitable and,
uh,
an interesting,
it's a simple,
simple little formula.
Thank you.
Okay.
Well there's one question I always like to ask.
Yes.
Which is what is the best piece of advice you've ever received?
Oh,
the one that stands out in your mind who were just like,
like somehow I've carried that with me or it wasn't just a really critical
moment.
Well,
my dad,
um,
when I was about 16,
I think applying to college,
um,
I was sat there and I said,
you know,
dad were,
where should I go?
Which,
you know,
and he said,
Martha,
um,
you're,
you're a smart girl.
You can do pretty much anything you want and you make up your mind.
And that was,
uh,
that was when he said,
you can do anything you want.
I think that that kind of encouragement is invaluable for life.
And let's talk a little bit about the future.
Oh,
where do you think the do it yourself industry is going?
Where does it go in the future?
In five years,
in 10 years?
How does it,
how does it change shape?
Well,
one reason that I'm on a book tour right now is because,
um,
you know,
after so many books,
do you think,
oh,
do you have to go on another book tour?
I get to see people face to face.
And um,
and last night at Macy's in Costa Mesa and south,
uh,
I guess that's south of La.
Um,
there were so many young people in line,
young mothers with babies.
So many babies came.
And this isn't it,
seven o'clock at night,
the babies were there,
the mothers,
young mothers were there,
their husbands were there.
Um,
I can see that the craving for good,
solid,
how to information is alive and well.
And I think that that's why the kind of work that I do in our company does,
in terms of teaching and inspiring is a,
is very important.
And,
um,
and if you forget how to learn even the homeliest chores,
you're not gonna,
you're just,
you can't live.
You can't.
And it's,
um,
you know,
we're not all billionaires.
We're not all millionaires.
Uh,
we all have challenges in life,
but knowing how to do things so things can be done well I think is very
important for the rest of your life.
And on that note today is the book has,
uh,
entertaining,
entertaining and entertaining.
Well,
uh,
we actually have books for the first two rows.
If you reach underneath your seat,
Oh,
where's that card underneath?
And you get a voucher for today's book.
Uh,
and Martin Martha's book.
We're going to have a book signing.
It's going to be in Seville tech talk from noon to one.
So Martha will be there,
uh,
signing books.
You can also buy the book.
They are so you can buy the book and how birth assignment get a chance to,
to,
to meet her for the next hour.
We're all going to go and show you some of what we're up to at x here at Google.
One and how are we doing?
How are we get things done here?
But this has just been so wonderful.
It's such an honor to have you here and you've been just so wonderful this
morning.
Let's give Martha a really warm
thank you.